翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさんこんにちは！
（拍手）
ようこそ！
本当に素晴らしいですね
みなさん笑顔が素敵で
さっき 後ろ聞こえてましたからね（笑）
ちょっと恥ずかしい気持ちで話しますけど
今日ですね 私が今までTEDxを運営してきて
学んできたことを共有したいと思います
まず質問があります
みなさんの中で コミュニティ運営
したことある方っていますか？
コミュニティ運営ってちょっと
仰々しいかも知れないんですけど
友達とか知人で
何か一緒に新しいことを
やり始めようと話したり
実際行動を始めたことがある方
どれぐらいいます？
あ 結構いますね
じゃあちょっと今日の話しなくていいかも
しれないですね　もしかしたら（笑）
そうですね 例えばこう
色んな人たちが集まっていく中で
色んな人たちを集めたいんだけど
人が集まらないとか
なんかお願いしたいんだけど
行動してくれないとか
色んな悩みありませんでした？
実は僕もそうでした
2009年まで僕は
プログラマーをしていました
今はコミュニティを運営する
コミュニティデザイン マネージメント
という仕事をしています
当然ギークな僕が
コミュニティをまとめてゆく
色んな人たちと話していくっていうことは
非常に大変で色んな失敗もありました
そこから学んできたことを
今日共有したいなと
そんな風に思っています
コミュニティって
一体なんなんでしょうか？
みなさん わかります？
人のつながりなんですよね
簡単にいうと
色んなつながりがあると思います
まずは生まれて家 血筋で
決定づけられる関係性
いわゆる血縁と呼ばれるものですね
あと 生まれた土地 育った場所で
決定づけられる関係性
地縁ですね 土地の「地」と書いて
「縁」と書いて「地縁」です
三つ目がですね
「社縁」と呼ばれる
就職した企業によって
決定づけられる関係性
言葉を変えると雇用関係で結ばれる
コミュニティといっていいかもしれません
今日僕がお話したいコミュニティは
その話をする前にちょっと一つ
やりたいことがあります
ちょっと 皆さん立って
いただいていいですか？
では お話したことのない隣の人と
ちょっとペア組んでください
ちょっと時間がないのでパッと
よろしいですか？（笑）
その人たちと
自分の好きなこと もの 何でもいいです
３つ挙げてみてください
いきますよ はい はじめてください
（話し声）
（話し声）（笑い声）
よろしいですか？大丈夫ですか？
じゃあ皆さん座っていただいて
いいですか？
この中で同じようなこと 共通の好きなこと
関心事があったっていうペア いますか？
お？お？いますね
今日お話する対象は コミュニティは
そういうものです
「知識」の「知」と書いて「縁」と書いて
「知縁」と呼びます
これは 知的好奇心で集まる
もしくは関心事で集まる
共感で集まるコミュニティのことを指します
このコミュニティっていうのは
みんなで知恵を出し合って
目的に向かって
何かを行動していったり
することもあります
あとはですね ボランティアで
活動するのが多いんですね
大きな 社縁とか地縁とか血縁と違うのは
全くもって強制力がない
そんなコミュニティを
どうマネージメントしていくのか
僕は色んな失敗を通じて
学んできたつもりです
では その５つの学びを
共有していきたいなと思います
まず１つ目は
ごめんなさいね
「楽しいが行動原理」です
僕は2009年にTEDxTokyoという
活動を始めたんですけども
それまでコミュニティで活動したことは
一切ありませんでした
どんなものか全く想像できなかったんです
あるとき 打ち合わせに行ったんですね
もう僕のイメージと全く違ったんです
最初僕のイメージしたものは
もうなんかみんな堅いスーツ着て
こう座って喧々諤々になって
真面目な話ばっかりずっとしてるのかと
思ってたら全然違ってて
それは大きなライブ会場の２階に
隠れ家みたいなカフェがあるんですけど
そこに集まって
アメリカ人 フランス人 インド人
デザイナー プログラマー
もう色んなコンサルタント マーケッター
色んな人たちが集まって
色んな話をしているんですよ
本題は全然行かないんですよね
もう１時間のミーティングで40分くらい
どうしようもない話をしてるんですけど
（笑）
それがすごい面白い
例えば恋愛話もしたりするんですね
「あの人好きになったんですよ」
「あ もういいよ その話は」みたいな（笑）
あと海外の今戦争が起きてる事情とか
色んな話をするんですよね
もう本当 知的な交流が
すごく行われてるんですね
僕はすごく興奮したんです
「This is so cool!」って
その時感じたんですね
こんな世界があったなんて
僕は全然知らなかったんです
TEDxの活動を通じて
他のコミュニティにも
遊びに行くようになったんですよ
そこで もちろんこう
TEDxのように面白いコミュニティもあれば
まったく こう
暗いコミュニティもあったんですね
その暗いコミュニティ
幾つかこう見てゆくと
共通点が見えたんですよね
まぁ 人が集まっていないんですけど
みなさんね 顔を見ると分かるんですよ
すごくつまらなさそうなんですね
まぁ 座ってて 僕が最初にイメージ
してたものと一緒ですね
いわゆる企業のあの
蛍光灯さんさんとした中で
座って なんか 結論の出ない会議を
延々としているような感じ？
（笑）あんなのが行われてるわけですよ
メンバー そのオーガナイザーと
話したら その人すごく悩んでて
「僕のビジョンと
このコミュニティのビジョンとを
活動をすごく共感してくれるんだ」と
「でもなかなか人が集まらない」
そのとき 僕は気付いたんですね
こういうコミュニティの場合には
楽しさってのはすごく重要
知的な好奇心をくすぐる何かっていうのを
そこで意図的にデザインしていかないと
人ってどんどん離れていってしまうんですね
非常に こう 離れやすいコミュニティに
なってくると注意が必要
なので最初から 例えば新しい人を
定期的に入れるとか
例えばテーマでも
みんなが興味あるものを入れたりとか
そういったことを意図的に
デザインすることが
求められてくるなと僕は思いました
で ２つ目はですね
「アンコントロールのデザイン」です
先ほど言った通り
様々な人たちが来るんですね
なのでライフスタイルも違えば
仕事の忙しさもまったく違うんですよ
中には 休みの日が
全然違うと言う人もいたりするので
一堂に会することがなかなか難しい
その中ですね
ある仲間が
当時その大きな企業で経営企画室を
やっていた仲間がいたんですけども
彼は会場チームということを
やっていたんですね
彼はまあ 普段から
忙しかったんですけれども
なかなか会場が決まらなくて
もうイベントも近づいてきて
みんなだんだん焦ってきてる
で 緊急会議をしようっていうことで
関係者集めて15人ぐらい集まって
打ち合わせすることになったんですよ
その１時間前にですね
彼から電話がかかってきたんですね
「どうやら中期経営計画が最初から
練り直さなければいけない」っていうので
「今から行けなくなってしまった」っていう
「おーい ここみんな集めたのお前のためだ」
という感じ（笑）
とにかく集まれない そのときこう ちょっと
僕はどうしようかな？と思ったんですね
まぁ 正直にみんなに話してみようと
思ったんですよ
で みんなに話したんですね
みんなも忙しい中こうなんとか
タイミングを合わせてきてくれたので
もしかしたら怒るかもしれないなと
思ったんですけれど
全然そんなことなかったんですね
「あいいよ いいよ じゃあ
今話せること決めていこうよ」
そこでこうみんなでいろいろな
ブレストして行きながら
結果的に登壇者も
そこで決まったりしたんですよ
僕がそこで感じたのは
あらかじめ決めて
何かをしようと思っても
なかなかこう人が集まらないわけですよ
こういうコミュニティって
みんな違うから ライフスタイルが
なのでそこでできることを
そのメンバーで出し合って
考えてゆくっていうことは
非常に重要だなと
いくらどんなにがんばって考えても
他の人のスケジュールとか生き方とかは
コントロールできないんです
なので その状況変化に対応するように
自分たちもその場その場で
対応していくというのが
非常に求められてくるな
と思いました
３つ目 「関り合いのマッチング」です
僕は2011年にTEDxKidsっていう
TEDxのフォーマットでも
子供向けにやるものを
やり始めたんですけども
そこでもいろいろなボランティアを募集して
一緒に活動していました
ある時友人の紹介で
ある女性がやってきたんですね
その女性はいつも通り
みんなで和気あいあいと
話しているんですけど
たまにこう なんかこう
机の上にのってずっと
見つめているんですよね みんなのことを
「何してんだろう？」と思ってね
で 話しかけにいくんですよ
そしたら
「どんなことをしたらいいいんだろうな？
って私悩んでいるんです」
って言ったんですね
じゃどんなことしたらいいんだろう？って
私なりにいろいろ考えて
そこで「こういう仕事があるよ
こういう作業があるよ」
って言おうと思ったんですね
でも僕はそこでぐっと堪えたんですよ
実はそのTEDxKidsを始める前に
僕っていろんな人に作業をお願い
しちゃってたことがよくあったんですね
で 作業をお願いしちゃうと
それは自分の仕事を
その人に分け与えているだけで
その人の仕事じゃないんですよ
分け与えられた仕事っていうのは
つまりこう 自分で積極的にやりたいと
思っているような仕事ではないので
それがたくさん来ちゃうと
みんなやめてっちゃうんですよね
僕もそんな失敗あったので
そこをぐっとこらえたんです
彼女も同じようなことを
３週間ぐらいずっとやってたんですよね
とあるときに
もう一回話したんですね
僕はお願いすることは
いつもしないんですけど
「こういう仕事があるよ 」
「こういう仕事があるよ」
「こういう仕事があるよ」って
投げかけるようにしてるんです
そうするときに 彼女が
「私 会社でいつも部屋にこもって
ずっと同じような人たちと
同じようなことばかり話してるんです」と
「大学生の時はNPOで色んな人たちと
会って未来ついて語り合ってたんです」と
それと「人と一杯コミュニケーションが
とりたいんです」って言ったんですね
参加者チーム
っていうのがありますね
さきほどパティシパントチームって
言ったと思うんですけど
まさにそれなんですけども
参加者の人たちと
対話を通じてその人たちの体験をデザイン
していくということがあります
それを 話したんですね
彼女がもう喜んで来るかなと
思ったんですけど来なくてね
「また考えます」って
―残念
一週間後 メールで 一文で
「私やります」って書いてあったんですね
そのあとの彼女の動きは物凄かったです
そのあと自分で何が必要か
タスクを全部洗い出して
参加者の人たちと
メールも頻繁にやりとりして
当時僕 TEDxKidsを始めたのが
初めてだったので
すごく忙しくて
あんまり色んなことに
目が向かなかったんですけども
彼女がいたお陰で
その辺は全部任せることができたんです
もし僕があそこで堪えずに
お願いしていたら
きっとこうはならなかったと
思うんですよね
そうやって人が色を塗れる
スペースを用意してあげて
そこで自ら色を[塗ることを]
後押ししてあげることが
非常に大事だなあと
僕はそこで感じました
「リーダーシップは地位ではなく行動」です
先ほどから何度もお話しているように
色んな人たちがくるんですね
その人たちの中では本当にやる気があって
「私がリーダーやりたいです！」
「僕がリーダーやりたいです！」
という人もでてきます
ただ その中の
僕の経験上なんですが
半分ぐらいは リーダーになっただけで
その後何もしなくなったんですよね
フェイスブックのタイトルをみると
なんかディレクターになってるけど
あんた何かしてるっけ？みたいな
―よくあるんです
そこからですね
僕はそういう相談が来る時
こう言うようになったんですね
「みんなの前で活動して
自分のこと証明して下さい」と
「そうすればみんなが認めて結果的に
あなたがリーダーになります」と
そういう風に言って
ちゃんと行動した人たちは
本当にうまいチームを
作り上げていくんですよね
なのでポジションを与えるんじゃなくて
その人の行動を喚起させるということが
非常に重要だなと思いました
例えばみんなどっかのコミュニティに
所属していて なんか活動していて
全く知らない人がリーダーですと言われても
なんだかよくわからないじゃないですか
その人が一生懸命活動して
誰よりもそのことに対して
真剣に行動していれば
みんな人って認めてくると思うんですよね
僕 それが非常に重要だなと
経験から感じました
５つ目がですね
「休憩のデザイン」です
本当に永くやっているとですね
メンバーのライフステージって
変わって行くんですよ
結婚したり 子供が生まれたり
もしくは転職したり
新しいプロジェクトを立ち上げたり
いろいろ忙しい
その忙しさが変わってくるんですね
で 前のように活動が
できなくなってくるんです
でも ずっと一緒にやってると仲間意識
みたいなのが芽生えてきちゃって
なかなか言い出しづらかったり
するんですよね
こうなんかしがらみみたいに囚われて
「なんか本当は忙しいんだけど
まあでも誘われたから行かなきゃ」
みたいな感じで行くと だんだんその人の
アウトプットの質も悪くなってくるし
なかなかこう 周りにも
変な影響が出てきてしまうので
私は毎年 「次の年 何しますか？」
っていうときに
必ず相談するようにしているんですね
もし 今 こういう何かが
始まっているんであれば
もしかしたら一回休憩した方が
いいかもしれません
という風に相談するようにしています
それで 僕はコミュニティの構成を
何層かに分けているんですね
コアチームというのは
いわゆる企画をするチームです
ここには本当にコミットできる人
僕はアクティビティ率と
呼んでるんですけど
それが
80％か90％くらい高い人たちしか
入らないようにしています
それは 入る前にみなさんに言っています
で 少しでもそういう風に
活動ができなくなったら
次の比較的ゆるいといいますか
そこまでコミットしなくてもいい
コミュニティに入って
もらうようにしています
そうすることによって
その人も自分の心地いい関係性を保ちながら
例えば何かソーシャルメディアをシェアして
欲しいときにシェアしてくれたりとか
もしくは忙しさが
その仕事がだんだん終わってきて
次の年はまた活動したいっていう人も
出てきたりするんですね
その人たちにとって
居心地のいいコミット感をできる層を
ちゃんと作っていってあげるっていうことが
非常に重要だなと思いました
最後にですね
色んな人たちに
「青木さん コミュニティ運営
しているときに どういうところを
最も大切にしていますか？」
って言われるんですね
僕はいつもこう答えています
「コミュニティの温度です」
どれだけその暖かさが
みんなに伝わってくるか
これを僕はよく
焚き火に喩えるんですけど
この中で焚き火をやったことある方
います？いますよね
火つけたことある方？
もしくはBBQの炭をやったことのある方？
なんか結構火をつけるの
大変じゃないですか 最初？
ティッシュとか小枝みたいなのを並べて
少し太めの枯れた木を置いて
火をつけて なかなか火がつかなければ
もう一回何個かやってみるって
形だと思うんですけど
一回火がついてしまうと
あとは太い木でもなんでも投入したら
どんどん燃えてゆくじゃないですか？
僕はコミュニティ運営っていうのは
それと一緒だなと思っているんですよ
最初にこのやる気とかの火をつけるのは
なかなか大変なんですけど
一度こうみんなが火点いちゃうと
もう何にもしなくていい
むしろ何にもしないほうがいい
たまにこう いろんな風が吹いて
火が消えそうになるときは
まぁちょっとこう
風あてを用意したりとか
もっと燃える木を
入れてみたりしながら
温度を調整していくということが
非常に大切だなと思ってます
一般的にみなさん
コミュニティっていうのは
ずっと続かなければいけない
ものだと思っている方が
もしかしたら多いかもしれません
でも 目的を達成したら そこで終わって
しまっても良いもんなんですね 実は
例えば BBQの炭を燃やしていて
料理ができたらやめますよね？
燃やしててずっと番をしていたらご飯が
食べられないじゃないですか？（笑）
そこで重要なのは
みなさん 一緒に
ご飯を食べることなんですよ
なので それは目的を達成したら
そこで終わると
そこで無理に続けると自分自身が
苦しくなるしメンバーも苦しくなるんです
それが非常に重要な視点かなと
僕は思ってます
そしてですね 世の中はいろんな課題に
溢れていると思うんです
ビジネスでは解決できない
ようなものもあるし
ビジネスとして捉えられる
ことができずに
なかなか企業が参加できない活動 出来事って
あると思うんですけども
色んな人たちが自分たちの知恵を
出し合いながら
楽しみながら参加できる場が
たくさんできていけば
もしかしたらお金なんか
必要ないんですよね
そういった場が
たくさん増えていくと
色んな課題が解決できて
くると思いませんか？
僕はできてくると思うんですよね
そういった世界が もしかしたら
子供に自慢できる
素敵な世界になるんじゃないかなと
僕は思っているんですよね
本日は ありがとうございました